What's up guys welcome back, thanks for joining us today on the king of random in the past
We've shown you how to make your very own backyard foundry using a metal bucket and this stuff called kaowool
Well this has worked out great. We've used it for a whole bunch of different projects and today
We're going to try and upgrade and build ourselves a larger foundry using this bigger
31 gallon trash can. The basic principle is that we have our metal trash can which will contain the heat nicely,
but it's very conductive and would easily let the heat escape out into the air, so we have this stuff called kaowool,
which is a very good insulator holds the heat in extremely well in fact you can put a blowtorch on one side of this and
your hand on the other side won't even feel it.
I don't think it's even warm after that...
So that's the plan. We'll line the whole can with the kaowool that way, we'll have the metal container
Which contains everything and the kaowool will hold in the heat.
Now that we know we're gonna do,
let's get started.
A quick note about the kaowool
It's a fiber substance a lot like fiberglass
So it's very irritating if it gets on your skin
Or especially if you breathe it in, so I'm going to be wearing a dust mask and that's why I have this long-sleeve shirt,
So it doesn't make my arms all itchy there we go
Hopefully that'll keep me from breathing in too many fibers as a first step
I want to add a lining at the bottom of our trash
can I'm going to set the trashcan on top of the kaowool and then trace around that I'll cut that circle out and
That will go in the bottom of our can
All right, we've got our circle cut out now. We're just gonna push that down into the bottom of our trash can
Now the kaowool is at the bottom of our trash can and that will insulate really well
But it's not very stable surface if we want to rest up on it here
We've got some compressed ceramic fiber board that will work as a stable base
It's a type of board that insulates really well and since it's rigid
It should be better for standing things on than just the kaowool
Now I probably want to cut this just a little bit inside of wearing mark because the very bottom of the trash can is just
The tiniest bit wider than the inside bottom of the trash
I suspect so we'll have a little bit of play?
Maybe if I cut it too small, but that'll still be better than having to be too big and not fitting
Alright, there's a circle that looks pretty good. Let's see if that fits in the bottom of our can ah
It's beautiful!
There we go a nice flat surface
That'll be much nicer and trying to balance stuff on unstable kaowool alright now
I'll try and take our kaowool and line the entire inside of it to figure out how much of this kaowool
I'm going to need them just gonna put the whole roll down in the can and
Then I'll unroll it onto the sides as much as I can and then mark where I want to cut it
Sort of start with it
inside there
get a nice and pressed up against the sides
of course the trash can is not a perfect cylinder, so it is a little bit wider at the top and the bottom
I'm gonna try and account for that
Alright, I'm gonna take my marker and mark
I'm gonna give myself some extra that I can later trim off as I do fine-tuning without all the weight of the extra kaowool
Getting in my way
Nothing's the trashcan is like I said very slightly tapered
Ideally our kaowool will would have a slight arc to it to fit perfectly around the edge
We're just going to fake it a little bit by cutting one sided a bit of an angle
And I think we'll get a pretty good fit
So I did the rough cut before
Now I'm going to see I
Can get that a little bit more refined you can see that the edges are overlapping by quite a bit at this point
This is where one side is so I'm going to mark that right there, and the other one is right here
and once again
I am going to give myself a little bit extra because it's better for it to overlap some than for there to be gaps
Right see how we did it is overlapping just a little bit
Which like I said, it's not a problem. Just take some squishing and persuasion there. We go that looking pretty good right there
The main body of the can is lined so now let's quickly cut out a piece the right size and shape for our lid
Wonder if a knife would be easier than scissors, so I'm just gonna try that and see if I like it any better
As you can see I am leaving an inch wide gap
That's the same thing that we did with our smaller foundry
This way when we push it into the lid it will have a little bit of pressure on it and help hold it in place
There we go
Hmm, I don't think it's gonna compress enough with that extra border I left on it
This lid has an interesting shape to it. There's a lip that extends off of the edge
I think by adding an additional inch to what was already added by the lip my kaowool is now too wide to fit inside
the inner area of this circle
So I'm gonna cut it down just to where I measured it with the marker and see if it fits any better
All right now we've got our slightly smaller circle. Let's see if that fits into our lid any better. Oh, yeah
That's exactly what you want
Being pushed in a little bit. It's not so tight that it won't fit
But it's big enough that it's still got some pressure holding it in
Hey, that's what we're hoping for and let's give it a try throwing it on our hand
Beautiful that should be one
Insulated trashcan at this point now
We've got the walls and the lid covered in our insulating kaowool and for now it's holding himself on really well
But with our mini foundry
Overtime as it got heated up and cooled down and heat it up and cooled down time after time the kaowool
Lost some of its rigidity and began to slump a little bit, so I've got some hardware
And I'm gonna use that to attach the kaowool to both the lid and the sides of the trashcan a little bit so that down
The road we don't run into that problem
The machine screw that I'm using here is a little longer than I need so I might end up replacing it later
That should hold it up pretty nicely now. I'm going to do the same thing at three points on the lid
Now no matter how much structural integrity this kaowool it should hold itself on pretty well, it's attached
Now we've got a very well insulated trashcan, but no way to add heat
So let's drill some holes into the sides and the lid so we have a place for the propane heat to go in and for
Some ventilation to go out
I'm gonna try and make the holes in our large foundry at the same height off the ground as the holes under mini foundry that
Way the wooden blocks that we use to support the burners will work at the same height
Plus if we have anything that's just on the bottom of our foundry. We'll know that it's getting the heat that it needs
Well that's smooth
Turns out a hole saw is not the very best tool for cutting through very thin steel
But it's what I've got so let's try it on the other side
That actually almost won smooth
All right just as an experiment to see if you try and use a hole saw on Kol what happens
Still not perfectly but much better
With those holes added I think our full size backyard foundry is ready to test with heat now
I do have a concern that the spacing of the hose with these was designed with the mini foundry in mind
And I'm not
Positive they'll stretch out far enough to really angle the way we want them to on the large trash can we'll see what we can
do
You might be alright
Alright, I did get both of them in and slightly angled
But as you can see the hose is being pulled really tight
And I don't think it's gonna cause any problems for our test
But we'll probably want to add a little bit extra hose before we use this foundry for any extended amount of burning
Whoo
That gets toasty quick
You can see that the burners aren't angled quite as much as it should be that's partly because our hose isn't long enough
So while it is heating it up pretty? Well. It's not really
Circling around quite as much as we like it to let's so the lid on and let this thing get really warm
Turned off I'm just gonna see oh
Ah that is toasty in there like the fire is not going but it still just really really warm
Inside there there you go that is how to make a large-scale backyard foundry. There are a few different things
We're thinking of trying with this foundry. It's obviously much larger than our normal backyard foundry which is gonna
Let us do a few more things with it
We'll be able to fit a large crucible, and we also might try firing some ceramics in this Forge
I also took some of our leftover cable, and I realign the mini furnace
And I was impressed at how easy it is to do that it only took me a couple minutes to completely replace the lining this
Is a great little furnace you can build and use and if the kale will get so old that's falling apart
It's very easier place in just a few minutes
I'm really looking forward to trying out some experiments with our large foundry to see what it can really do
Thanks for joining us for this project and we'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then
Seems like a Captain America shield and this one's like a Captain cotton shield
not a very good shield
Hey guys. I hope you're having a great day. You are awesome
You are appreciated, and I know everyone over here on my team is really grateful for you
Thanks so much for choosing to watch and support our videos. We'll see you in the next one